oh hi we are here at game developers
conference in San Francisco where once
again video game developers are getting
together learning about the art and
business of making games and once again
one of the biggest exhibitors here is
Nintendo who has got just they finished
up their keynote address Satoru Iwata
president Covino and he had a lot of
really interesting announcements he said
that virtual console arcade is actually
going to launch today so go on to your
ween you can start downloading classic
arcade games like Space Harrier and mapi
he announced a brand new Legend of Zelda
game called spirit tracks for the
Nintendo DS which is a lot like phantom
hourglass except for instead of riding
around in a boat you can now ride around
on a train it looks really really cool
another announcement that he made was
that more final fantasy games are going
to be coming to wii ware and Virtual
Console the original classic Final
Fantasy 16-bit 8-bit RPGs on Virtual
Console and a sequel to Final Fantasy 4
called the after years is going to be
available on wiiware and that's all this
year the theme of the keynote seemed to
be yes we do still care about you
hardcore gamers here's a bunch of games
you're really going to be interested in
in fact look this guy behind me it's
playing punch out for the wii i'm gonna
go i'm gonna go check that out we'll see
you guys later